así
muy bien ya tenemos las matemáticas que
buscamos para hacer un programa que
dibuje tantas líneas como necesitemos
para hacer una aproximación a una
parábola vamos a regresar a los aspectos
artísticos del pasto empezando con el
ancho en este interactivo puedo mover
los puntos y no muestra las líneas del
polígono controlador para que sea un
poco más simple así que vamos a ver
esta es la forma de la curva que se ve
muy bien es la que quiero déjame moverme
al siguiente paso que es definir el
ancho y eso lo voy a hacer usando algo
que llamamos esqueleto el esqueleto es
un conjunto de líneas como estas que
pasan a través de la hoja del pastor en
un ángulo de 90 grados entonces esta es
una línea esqueleto aquí hay otra y así
sucesivamente y ahora si conecto todos
los lados izquierdos de las líneas
esqueleto y todos los lados derechos de
las líneas esqueleto creo una región y
si ahora la rellenamos observa que esa
región ya se parece más a una hoja de
pasto
y puedo controlar el ancho usando este
deslizador de aquí eso simplemente
ajusta la longitud de las líneas
esqueleto
este ancho se ve muy bien y bueno
finalmente puedo controlar el color
puedo ir desde un verde obscuro a un
verde brillante hasta un verde muy
brillante nuestros artistas controlan
parámetros como este para crear un pasto
convincente como el que visten valiente
usa este interactivo para ver qué tipos
de hojas de pasto puedes crear y en el
siguiente vídeo hablaremos sobre cómo
animarlo